today we'll be speaking with Saul cassen
whose distinguished professor of
psychology at John Jay College of
Criminal Justice in New York City and
also professor emeritus of psychology at
Williams College in Massachusetts he is
author of the book duped why innocent
people confess and why we believe their
confessions I really appreciate your
time today I'm glad glad to have you on
I'm very very happy to be here so
anecdotally we all hear stories of
innocent people who confess to crimes
they did not commit I think a natural
reaction a common reaction is to say I
would never do that I can't imagine any
circumstances in which police sit me
down and they suspect me for a crime and
I know I didn't commit it I would never
ever ever confess to a crime I didn't
commit and yet it happens all the time
can you tell us a little bit about why
this happens
you're absolutely right I think the
first myth that has to be debunked is I
would never confess to a crime I did not
commit yeah answer yes you would
and uh you will note that there are two
titles to the title of my book one is
why innocent people confess and two why
we believe their confessions we are
duped into believing false confessions
so when those of us who are presented
with a confession and we're thinking an
innocent person would never do this
we can't see past a false confession it
looks true it sounds true it feels true
I would never do that innocent people
don't do that wrong
imagine yourself being brought in as a
suspect in a crime you're taken into the
station you're alone you're isolated
you're not with family you're not with
friends if you're a kid you're asking
can I call my mother and the answer is
not till we're done here
and then you come in and the detective
walks in and slaps a folder on the table
and says we know you committed this
crime and we have a boatload of evidence
against you
and that's how that session proceeds
privately without you having any access
to outside sources of information or
people and that goes on sometimes for
hours
until the officer the detective or
detective's plural offers you something
of a way out you know I think you're a
good person I don't think you intended
to do this maybe this was just something
your friends put you up to or or you had
one too many drinks and they start to
make it sound as if the consequence
would be minimal you want out
you believe for whatever reason they
seem to have this overwhelming evidence
against you and you've been denying this
for hours and they keep calling you a
liar every time you deny it
you're trying to get out of the
situation and now they're offering you
an escape hatch the Escape patch is you
know what just cooperate with us we
think we think you're a good person we
don't think you meant to do this
and before you know what you're signing
a statement believing that that
signature and that statement is in your
best interest it sounds like to some
degree you know we've talked with
attorneys about the kind of plea deal
industrial complex and some of the
circumstances including being able to
get out of pre-trial detention including
a known smaller penalty than chancing
the possibility of a much stricter
penalty we've talked about that it seems
that there are some similar Dynamics
between that and false confessions
although they clearly are two different
things and they relate to the isolation
the disproportionate power that Dynamic
that exists and the unknown of it could
be even worse if I stick to my guns
that's exactly right and what a what a
perfect parallel to plea bargaining that
you just described because they are the
same process people are making what a
decision-making theorist would say is a
rational decision given the information
they have they're trying at this point
to cut their losses and you know what's
interesting about the parallel between
the confession that a suspect gives to
police in an interrogation room and then
the guilty plea confession that they
give in court to prosecutors and defense
lawyers
it's the same Dynamic but here's what's
interesting
people who have confessed to police are
then later more likely to accept the
false guilty plea why because everybody
correctly is telling them if you go to
trial you're going to get convicted
so the confession now gives rise to and
spawns a false guilty plea
and you know I've got a whole chapter in
this book about this system of ours
being obsessed with confession it
happens One More Time Imagine the person
who confesses later pleads guilty is
sitting in prison and is now eligible
for parole and they have to appear
before a parole board well guess what
they can't get out until they accept
responsibility and show they've been
rehabilitated and so I've spoken and
worked on cases of exonerees who
confessed and then said the most galling
next thing I ever had to do in my life
was reconfest years later in order to
become
paroled and once again here's the system
not understanding that the Baseline
level of wrongful conviction it's not
zero guys may have been conceived of a
zero fifty years ago we now know it's
not zero
when there is a confession and the
confession isn't thrown out when it's
thrown out it we can put it in another
category but when there's a confession
that makes it into an eventual trial
um is it overwhelmingly difficult to to
overcome that when when there is an
accepted confession as part of a trial
um once first of all I seldom see
confessions that are suppressed from
evidence yeah they almost always are
admitted these days the question a judge
will ask of the suppression hearing is
well did he wave his Miranda Right did
he did he receive and wave his Miranda
rights yes well then it's a voluntary
statement that's that becomes proof of
voluntariness Miranda is a whole
separate problem yes in this business
um so so now that now the person comes
to court and there's a confession in
evidence
I don't want to overstate it but almost
nothing else matters in the infamous
Central Park jogger case for example
people don't realize this
those kids confessed on videotape they
were induced after 14 to 30 hours of
questioning to confess and only the
confession was on tape not the and just
so people know sometimes this is known
as the Central Park 5 case it's the same
we're talking about the same case yeah
yes and they've all been exonerated
since fully exonerated
um what people don't realize is after
they confess and before they went to
trial the the jogger was raped and there
was a rape kit and there were several
Siemens samples and those samples were
sent to the crime lab and when those
samples came back here was the result
all of the different semen samples Trace
to a single individual not five not six
one person
and that person was not one of the five
confessors the confessors were excluded
so they come to trial with their
confessions no other supporting
corroborating evidence contradictory DNA
evidence and they were convicted that's
how powerful confession evidences almost
nothing else matters once that is in
evidence as a general question how
relevant in these situations is some
level of Education as well as the
financial access to a lawyer and the
reason I ask that is in my mind
I would never even go in to talk to
police voluntarily number one if I had
to go in I would absolutely get a lawyer
and if I was arrested and then you know
if it wasn't a situation where they call
and say hey would you like to come in if
I'm arrested and brought in I would say
literally not a word other than I want a
lawyer which seems like it would help me
in in this situation or even when doing
that do you still see false confessions
um man you're asking all the asking all
the right questions
um so myth number one I would never
confess to a crime I didn't commit myth
number two is I'd know a false
confession if I saw one if I sat on a
jury and this was an innocent person I
know it okay wrong would not okay the
third myth is that Miranda protects us
that our Miranda rights matter
um here here's here's one fact that was
discovered within one year of the
Supreme Court's Miranda decision that
roughly 80 percent of people wave their
rights right out of the gate yes and we
now know that that number is holding
steady and higher here's what else we
know you know who's the most likely to
waive their rights
innocent people
when I work on cases involving false
confessors who are later fully DNA
exonerated without dispute their
factually innocent
I asked him two questions one why did
you confess
and the second question is when things
got ugly why don't you call a lawyer why
didn't you stop talking and call a
lawyer
every one of them says the same thing in
almost the same words I didn't need a
lawyer I didn't do anything wrong
innocent people don't understand the
peril they have some fundamental belief
in the power of their innocence to
Prevail they have some fundamental
belief in the world as a place that is
more just than this
and so they figure you know I'll talk
we'll talk they'll see I didn't do this
very often when the police imply or
outright State we have evidence we've
got prints we're sending off to the lab
now that sounds like a threat we've got
you we've got Prince to the innocent
person imagine yourself innocent and you
know you're innocent they say they've
got Prince you've been here for hours
and you want to get out and you're
thinking Prince that's going to show my
innocence to the innocent person that
threat that bluff of having evidence
is a promise of future exoneration um
and so they think okay I've been here
for 19 hours I can't take it anymore
where do I sign and when the prints come
back you'll see I didn't do this I don't
know the law around you mentioned 19
hours 13 hours 14 hours this is sort of
a an interlude but I I don't know the
law around that but if you ask for a
lawyer right away is a lawyer going to
allow you to be there for 19 hours or
does a lawyer prevent that from even
becoming the situation
a lawyer seldom
people sell the mask for a lawyer right
away and part of it too is and this gets
to some points about Miranda first of
all people don't fully understand their
rights
and you know Miranda is something we
hear we hear it on Law and Order
everybody can recite the words by heart
you know almost almost by memory and yet
uh when you when you measure people's
comprehension of the rights themselves
and how that operate them it's amazing
how little comprehension people have so
for example
um what if you come in and you don't
realize that you're a suspect
um and you think maybe you're a
cooperating witness and you're not sure
that the police are about to fully
accuse you yep but they read you your
Miranda Rights to say we'd like to talk
to you but we can't really do that until
we get past this formality and so I'd
like to read your rights you've heard
them a million times before but you have
the right to remain silent anything you
say can be used against you
the suspect says yes yes yes I
understand where do I sign and they sign
away that waiver
now
what if things start to get ugly
ask the average person
are you able once you've signed a waiver
of your rights are you able to reinvoke
them later
the answer is yes right A lot of people
don't know the answer is yes so there's
one aspect of comprehension that people
lack people think once they've signed
off on that waiver that's it
and they worry also about the Optics of
Silence
and of course for innocent people they
don't understand the Peril of talking
right and so they do and so the people
that require in some sense the greatest
protection those accused who are
innocent they're not going to use that
protection
and so it tends not to happen now as far
as the time frame you mentioned the
average interrogation only lasts for 30
minutes to an hour and if you want to
Encompass 90 to 95 of all percent of all
interrogations it's a couple of hours
when you look at the database of
wrongful convictions in which people
gave false confessions now you're
looking at eight hours ten hours 16
hours 20 hours
time breaks people down
time breaks people down because we start
to get lonely I don't mean that in a
clinical sense but people need others
around and they need social support
especially when times get stressful yeah
they need someone to check in with they
need breaks they need to get they need
sleep sleep deprivation is accompanied
by these 20-hour sessions
um
food breaks you know so it's both it's
both biological and social needs and
fatigue sets in
I I've worked on cases where I literally
did a a count of the number of times the
innocent person said I didn't do this
and was called a liar sometimes that
happens over a hundred times in an
interrogation so if you want out if
you're exhausted if you can't take it
anymore and every time you deny
involvement they call you a liar and you
realize this isn't my way out of here
you've got to try something else last
thing I want to ask about you write in
the book about the Amanda Knox murder
case in Italy there's a Netflix
documentary about that and if I recall
generally speaking this is a case in
which Amanda Knox an American was
accused of a murderer along with I
believe it's a guy she may have been
romantically involved with of a of a a
third person a woman
can you talk a little bit about what
happened in that one and how it's
relevant to what you write about
you know it's such a perfect
illustration of something that's so
important to know when people hear that
an innocent person confess knowing as
you opened with I would never do that a
normal person would never do that
everyone's first reaction is what's
wrong with that person yeah that what is
they immediately make an attribution to
something is wrong with that person who
did this they don't think about the
situation that person was in that might
afflict just about anybody
Amanda Knox was a 20 year old American
student in Italy smart smart kid
but she was in Italy she wasn't fluent
in the language and her roommate was
murdered in a vile way and she was the
person who discovered the crime scene
and called it in and over the course of
four days for no good reason she was
identified as a suspect
for no good reason and I I could catalog
the the numbers of demeanor cues oh she
did that she looked like this she looked
like that she didn't cry enough she
cried too much that were used to
identify her as a suspect to the point
where she was interrogated on and off
for four and a half days for over 50
hours
culminating in a final night where they
brought her in told her that that
romantic that person she was
romantically involved with who was with
her that night that he disavowed her
Alibi that he said he wasn't with her
that night
now it's now five in the morning she's
confused she's been at this for days her
mother like her mother said maybe we
should come and get you and bring you
home and she says no I think I can help
them with this
so she stayed back and had that
phenomenology of Innocence where she
didn't appreciate the Peril she was in
she didn't when I asked her about this
she didn't realize she was a suspect
until the very last moment
and then at five six in the morning they
hand write a confession in Italian and
get her to sign it and she confesses
and then they take another confession a
couple hours later and as soon as she as
soon as she has a little sense of mind
and she's left alone she immediately
realizes oh my God I'm so confused and
she hand writes a recantation of that
confession yes but in the meantime the
Amanda Knox case shows something else
she confesses within two weeks there's
DNA splatter all over the crime scene
they find the guy who did it and he has
a criminal background and he fled to
Germany right after the I mean they they
got the guy
but they would not overturn her
confession and they proceeded to
prosecute her and the boyfriend despite
having DNA all over the place from
another person
by the time she got to trial and this
this tells a lot about confession cases
by the time she got to trial it wasn't
just her confession
her friends turned against her new
Witnesses came out of the woodwork
forensic analysts were misinterpreting
forensic evidence in ways that suggested
her guilt
it illustrates something other some
other point about confessions
when somebody confesses to a crime they
didn't commit all of a sudden it
corrupts that confession once the word
gets out corrupts other Witnesses right
corrupts forensic scientists and so by
the time a Confessor an innocent
Confessor gets into the courtroom
they face a mountain of evidence which
is really nothing but a house of cards
built on a back of a false confession
and that's what happened to her
she appeared in court and all of a
sudden there's this parade of lying and
non-credible Witnesses and forensic
examiners who are not correctly
interpreting the data and you know her
case has ultimately been resolved
Italy's Supreme Court said so declared
her innocent was critical of the
prosecutor for for the case to begin
with yeah but but she went through hell
and and part of the reason she went
through hell was the constant surprise
of witness after witness who appeared in
light of her confession yep that that's
a quite a quite a um emblematic story of
exactly what you write about in the book
I'll remind you the book is duped why
innocent people confess and why we
believe their confessions we've been
speaking with the book's author Saul
Cason I really appreciate your time
today
pleasure it's a pleasure